foreign
[Music]
welcome also from my side and yeah thank
you for joining
um our today's webinar thinking
translational things to consider in Katy
research workflows
yeah and please briefly acknowledge also
our disclaimer displayed here on this
slide
taking a look at our today's agenda we
firstly take a look at the past to sell
therapies from early Discovery to
commercialization and the challenges and
needs that you might face in the
different phases then I will elaborate
the key points to consider to ease up
the transition from small scale to
large-scale Manufacturing
and then I will also talk about suitable
tools that we have been developing that
enable a smooth transition from the
small scale research setting to the
large-scale manufacturing workflow and
of course end up with a summary and some
links and resources
I'd like to start off with a question so
what's your vision when it comes to
cartoon cell therapy
I'm sure that every one of us has his or
her personal goals but beside that the
overall vision is
to develop car teas that work translate
them into the clinics and successfully
treat cancer patients all over the world
however as we all know it's quite a long
way starting from basic research and
Discovery to pre-clinical development to
the different different clinical phases
to a marketed therapy that really makes
a difference in patients life
and especially Salon Gene therapies come
along with a lot of hurdles and
challenges which is especially true for
such novel therapeutic approaches using
that living drugs like car T cells and
of course the challenges differ from
face to face in a research setting you
need to narrow down targets develop safe
car T cells validate them
in Vivo and in vitro in the
translational phase you need to transfer
your small scale protocol to a large
scale process and later on you also need
to take care of regulatory requirements
deal with increasing numbers of patients
and of course always keep an eye on the
costs
foreign
and of course although the needs will
change at the discovery phase you need a
high degree of flexibility and a diverse
set of methods whereas later on
standardization and process
automatization process automation will
be key and by this it becomes obvious
that the price to Cartesian therapy is
not an easy one
however it's doable as reflected by the
increasing number of commercial Cartier
cell products and by today already six
therapies are marketed to treat cd19 and
pcma positive malignancies
and a lot more are in the pipeline by
today a total of
1115 clinical trials are initiated and
the numbers are rapidly increasing as
shown by this graph here on the right
hand side
the drugs are currently tested in
clinical studies worldwide underwent the
depicted path and have had a need for
phase specific Solutions and for the
solutions that enable a transition from
one phase
from one phase to the other
and asmutiny is very active in the field
of saline gene therapy we also
experience such challenges and hurdles
and developed integrated workflow
Solutions and tools such as a research
workflow translational research workflow
as well as clinical workflow and patient
monitoring workflows
but now you may ask what distinguished
miltony from all the other solution
providers so well our corporate mission
is to advance scientific research in
Medicine by providing solutions for a
Curative cell and gene therapy as well
as biomedical research and this mission
is the backbone of the company and
influences our daily work from research
to clinical from r d to marketing and
given our Maxi may come to history
Mutiny is very active in the field of
cell and gene therapy our r d department
is working on the development of car
therapies reflected by several
scientific Publications conference
contributions as well as many
collaborations with academic labs and
consortia for example the karate or the
tea to evolve Consortium
and this also led to a proven track
record of our solutions by scientific
Publications in high impact journals and
clinical party cell trials
and given our great expertise and
experience in the carti research as well
as in the manufacturing field we want to
share now within the next chapter some
of the considerations to streamline the
transition from the small scale research
setting to the large-scale clinical
manufacturing of carti cells
first of all it's always helpful to know
right from the start where the journey
is going through and thinking
translational as this webinar of today
is named pays off at the end it not only
saves time but also May reduce costs and
it's easy on the nerves so taking a look
at the reagents for example here the
questions should we are my reagents
available in GMP quality
are this the same clones and formulation
or does this differ and how does this
influence my process also in terms of of
their unpacking is in in large scale is
it then backs where those flasks in in
small scale what is about the supply
chains are my reagents available
worldwide are they stable at room
temperature if I produce an asset
Factory
um say a factory environment and what is
about my antibodies that I am using in
my panels are they really reproducible
what is that what is about my in-process
control do I already have suitable
antibody panels or do I need to
re-establish them when I switch from
small scale research to a large scale
Manufacturing
if it comes to to the device
I will need for sure automation what is
about the scalability as the process
then easy to scale up
um is there a proven track record does
other people other the community uses
this
um this device what is about the
robustness and also what's also super
important is the technical support what
is if something is happening do I have
technical support on my device
then in terms of the methods
um are the methods translatable to an
automated system
what is about the time of the essay can
I shorten it because time in the end is
also influences the cost are my methods
really reliable how many readouts do I
need and do I want to have does my
method fit the purpose is the essay
suitable for a QC in a clinical setting
and is are those essays already used in
clinical trials
and all those considerations if you make
them if you put some thoughts in it up
front this will really streamline the
transition from small scale research to
large-scale Manufacturing
yeah we follow the workflow depicted
here on this slide starting from human
blood products followed by cd4cda T Cell
isolation the activation of the T cells
via CD3 cd28 receptor engagement
followed by Gene delivery by viable
transduction or electroporation then the
X Vivo expansion of the car T cells as
well as a phenotypic and functional
verification at the end of the workflow
in a research setting and this is also
quality control in a clinical setting of
the final product and we integrated and
developed a broad range of products that
are used in research and clinical
setting and yeah using such products
already in the research phase
um
enables for a seamless transition or
lows allows for a seamless transition of
your whole research workflow to the
Clinic's Prodigy platform where GMP
compliant car T cells can be
manufactured automatically and in a
closed system
automating and closing of manual steps
makes manufacturing more scalable robust
reliable and consistent to enhance the
product quality and yeah human error is
frequently identified as one of the
highest risk elements of the
manufacturing process leading to
protocol variations and batch faders so
automation mitigates the risks by
providing repeatable and reliable cell
processing and keeping that in mind I
would like to introduce our clinomax
Prodigy platform to you for those of you
who do not know it now um by now
um yeah this is our hands off end-to-end
process platform and I just want to
quickly introduce the key features to
you
so it is an integrated and flexible
platform with one close consumable and a
reduced footprint so it's not too big
and it's also fully automated so fully
automated platform and that absolutely
increases the reproducibility and
standardization
it's a closed system but with an
in-process quality in process control
and quality control sampling
um that you can increase the robustness
of your process and it comes along with
a flexible software and parameterization
um and what is also really nice is that
the climax property platform is used in
more than 180 clinical trials worldwide
so far
yeah as I just mentioned the cleaner Max
productive platform is very flexible and
comes along with a lot of processes and
one process is the T-cell transaction
process ensured the TCT process and
which includes the seaside separation
activation transduction and expansion as
previously mentioned and yeah it is for
the automated manufacturing of car T
cells starting from different blood
products there are two enrichment
strategies available you can customize
your culture conditions and you of
course can do a retroviral and
lentiviral strength transduction
strategies
yeah especially for the TCT process we
have a proven track record in T-cell
engineering and yeah from Smart scale
research to large-scale manufacturing
with our clinimax Prodigy and from 2016
on to 2022 now we have a lot of
pre-clinical data and Manufacturing
optimization different publication and
peer-reviewed
journals as well as first clinical
results I do not go into detail
um but this is yeah the customer
experience regarding this tip yeah
furthermore the TCT process the T Cell
transaction process on the Clinic's
Prodigy as an application is already
used in several clinical trials
worldwide to manufacture car T cells
yeah so after this short excuse to their
clinical to the Clinic's Prodigy and the
T-cell transduction process for the
clinical manufacturing we are now coming
back to the translational research
workflow and we want to take a closer
look at the workflow itself and look at
what is important to consider to ease up
the transition from this Moscow research
setting to the large-scale manufacturing
to shorten the development time
yeah depicted here on this slide you can
see the translational research workflow
through the experimental time scheme of
it and
um yeah I will just let you through it
so we started with the T-cell isolation
on day Zero followed by the stimulation
of the isolated T cells we also did the
immune cell composition analysis by flow
of the isolated T cells before and after
enrichment we also checked for the
activation prior to activation
and the activation was also checked
throughout the whole
um
procedure we perform the gene delivery
on day one after activation we washed
away our activation reagent on day three
and we also used flow analysis panels
for to assess their um
the stem memory T Cell phenotype and of
course after activation the expansion
period took place until day 22.
yeah looking at the first step the T
Cell isolation in a research setting
several methods are frequently used some
start directly with pbmc so no
enrichment at all others go for
parentiesel isolation or others can go
for positive selection for example of
CD4 and cd80 cells and when it comes to
translation there are some questions
some conditions some considerations
coming up namely
um the optimal reproducibility of of the
results by the different methods by the
different approaches other reagents
available in GMP quality so for example
pantiesel isolation kit or cd438
microbeads and it's the isolation method
translatable to an automated system so
if you go for pbmcs this is translatable
and other clinical processes already
established or available or is there a
proven track record
does someone already someone already
doing it
yeah so we always go for cd4cd at
positive selection and I will also let
you know why this is beneficial for the
whole process and so we assess the
immune cell composition using a
predefined antibody panel before and
after the T Cell isolation with CD4 cd8
microbeads and you can see the numbers
of the three different donors and these
graphs nicely show the heterogeneity of
their um in the cell composition in the
starting material here Buffy coats and
this heterogeneity would be even more
obvious if we have been if we would use
a patient material
but however after the enrichment the
amount of CD4 ncda T cells between the
different
donors was comparable and this means
that we start with a more comparable and
more homogeneous sample which then
clearly leads to a higher
reproducibility of the whole process
yeah additionally we observed a
correlation between the number of
between the numbers of monocytes in the
starting material and the transduction
efficiency
and the hypothesis here is that the
monocytes eat up the virus and as shown
on the figure on the right hand side
here and this also leads to the
conclusion that pre-enrichment is also
beneficial for the transduction
efficiency to improve their transduction
efficiency
yeah besides the higher reproducibility
and the improved transduction efficiency
if we remember the considerations the
CD4 cd8 micro bits are also available in
so they are available in research grade
as well as in Max GMP quality the
positive isolation is compatible with
the Clinic's privacy Prodigy and T cell
transduction and T Cell tce process for
the T Cell Electro electroporation and
our Max microbeads are already used in
clinical trials worldwide
if you find yourself in a research
setting still working with research
products we have two app options
available that I want to highlight here
one option is to isolate pbmcs from
blood products and continue with the one
on one one-to-one mixture of CD4 and cd8
microbeads including
um the size the ficol this will take
approximately two hours
and yeah as time is money we are using
our straight from microbeads frequently
and those micro bits or straight from
microbeads are added directly to the
plot products
and by this you can process for example
an entire Buffy code within only 30
minutes and yeah both are positive
selection approaches and thereby are
translatable to a large scale
manufacturing at The Prodigy and they
are 100 comparable
so in more detail on day one the tea
sets of each donor were transduced with
equal amounts oh yeah
Pacific
on day one two thirds of each donor were
transduced with equal amounts of
antiviral particles encoding a cd20
directed car and the transition
transduction efficiency was analyzed by
flow cytometry using a cd20 card
detector reagent and human and
independently of the manufacturing
protocol so if you go for standard
straight from microbeads for the
standard microbeads
um we observed a comparable transduction
efficiencies on day six as well as on
day 12 there were no significant
difference
um and to assess the
um where to assess and compare the
cytotoxic cytolytic potential of the
cd20 directed car T cells and cd20
positive gecko-1 cells where cochitect
risk RT is derived from two different
protocols at different effector to
Target cell ratios
um for in total 20 hours and yeah
analyzing both targets analyzers as well
as the release of pro-inflammatory
cytokine like gmcsf and the front gamma
il2 and tnf Alpha and we could confirm
that there's no significant difference
in regards to cytotoxic potential of
both cellular products so by this we
could confirm that
there's no difference between the
straight from microbeads and the
standard microbeads but the straight for
microbeads are of course the faster
option
yeah independent of the approach you
decide for standard microbeads or the
straight from cd468 microbes the basis
is always our Max technology but why is
it so beneficial to use the max
Technologies for car T Cell engineering
for T Cell engineering immune cell
manufacturing so our technology is based
on the max columns and through the
columns the magnetic field can be or is
Amplified by a 10 000 fold and this
allows us to reduce
the number of beads of this Nano size
Max microbeads
um
and this leads them to a minimal
labeling of the self
and further there is a large space
between the steel spheres of the color
Matrix and that enables a free flow
through of all the non-labeled cells and
an enrichment of the minimal labeled
cells without any unspecific activation
and yeah if you if you take a look at
the electron microscopy images here at
this side comparing a column three
system versus our Max technology
you can clearly see the bead Aggregates
on the surface of the cells if you go
for column free system where it says
isolated with the max technology due to
the minimal labeling look really really
natural and healthy
and yeah taking all these benefits into
account it becomes clear why our Max
technology our column based technology
is already used in clinical Cell Therapy
trials worldwide
now as we have enriched our T cells with
straight from microbeads or the CD4 ct8
standard microbeads we can continue with
the stimulation of our iOS isolated T
cells
um and also performing flow analysis to
check for the activation of the T cells
for this workflow step the physiological
activation of T cells and then the
efficient expansion and there are also
several options available so T-cell
activation via and nanometrics a
beat-based T Cell Activation or also
functional grade antibodies to perform
the CD3 cd28 stimulation of the T cell
yeah what are the key considerations for
this workflow step so are my results
reproducible with my um activation
method other reagents available in GMP
quality are the activation reagents
suitable to an automated closed system
um do I have control of it and it's a
clinical process already established and
available is there a proven track record
of of this um this reagents for the
clinical phase and also what is about
the safety of these um these reagents
we considered such things and we meet
the needs and developed a product this
is named T Cell transact and this meant
for physiological Act was developed or
has been developed for the physiological
activation of T cells and for the
efficient expansion and what makes this
reagent special so it's a colored Dell
polymeric Nano Matrix that is conjugated
to CD3 and cd28
um agonists it can be dosed
volumetrically and it can be removed by
a simple wash step so there's no need to
add any chemicals or
bead removal step and it is
physiological and it enables a
physiological and robust stimulation of
the enriched T cells in our kcd4 cd8 and
it's also suitable for an automated
manufacturing platform due to this
features as volumetric dosage and
removal by a wash step due to this Nano
Matrix and it's also available in
research grade as well as in Max GMP
quality and transact is also already
used in clinical cardi trials worldwide
yeah proceduralize the T cells were
pelleted and was suspended at a
concentration of 10 to the power of 6
cells per ml in Tex-Mex medium
supplemented with our T-cell transact
and cytokines so here we used il7 and
il15 and from the cell suspension 2ml we
are filled into a 24 well blade and
incubated for 24 hours and 24 hours
after seeding the T Cell the gene
transfer was done
and yeah three days after the activation
the activation medium was replaced by
Tex-Mex supplemented with il-7 and il15
and yeah they're um
um Gene modified cells were split at
least every third day or when the cells
of course are confluent or exceeded a
Confluence of 70 they were also split
and then we did flow analysis on day 3 8
3 6 8 13 15 and 17 and using the T Cell
Activation panel consisting of CD3 ct4
cd8325 cd69 and CD 137
applying the T-cell activation panel
including the micro CD3 CD4 cd8 cd25
cd69 and CD 137 and we observed that all
three markers were upregulated upon the
Cell Activation using T-cell transact
via TCR signaling but with different
kinetics and CD 137 and
cd69 and they are very early activation
markers and they are usually detectable
within hours after the T-cell receptor
ligation and the other expression is
induced and after 48 to 60 at 96 hours
the expression then decreases and goes
back to the Baseline
as shown here
um
yeah for the other market for
cd25 this is the alpha chain of the il2
receptor and this is up regulated a bit
later usually then cd69 and CDM 137
um
but it's also detectable on day one and
the data are not shown here but what
it's shown here is that the ct6 CD at 25
expression remains High out today 8 to 9
and then starts to go down after day
eight
foreign
period of 14 days we applied T Cell
transact again to induce or to see if
the T cells can be restimulated and what
we've seen is that there was again an
upregulation of CDA 137 as well as cd69
and cd25
um
yeah additionally to the data I've shown
I also want to highlight the safety
aspect of T-cell transact of the max
gmpt cell transact because using
immunomodulatory substances for the
manufacturing of cellular products for
for example Advanced T Cell therapies a
safety assessment of the reagent that I
used is essential to identify potential
risks associated with there are two
their use and yeah with several
experiments we demonstrated the safe use
of the max gmpt cell transact on the
automated cleaner Max producty platform
using the previously mentioned TCT
application software and I don't want to
go into detail but highlight that T-cell
transact is really a robust and potent
polyclonality Cell Activation and
expansion tool for clinical scale
manufacturing of modified T cells and um
yeah if you're interested in more
details in the data then you can scan
the key the QR code here and this will
let you to the to the poster
yeah next you would like to take a look
at the expansion of our
um transduced or electroporated T cells
so how can we ensure a highly efficient
expansion
and here as well you're basically two
options so of course you need medium and
cytokines but you can go for a medium
without serum or
um yeah a serum three medium and a
cytokine cocktail and also in this T
Cell expansion
Pros process step there are several
considerations so for example are my
cell culture results really reproducible
and how can I ensure this as well as are
my reagent again available in GMP
quality and in research quality
is my medium available with and without
final red if I need it if I would like
to have it
um what is if I switch from bottles
to back so from flask to bags from
research to a clinical setting and what
is about the unique specific dosing
and yeah after a successful transaction
the teachers were expanded as said and
this was done in um
zero free Tex-Mex medium and Max
cytokines il7 and il-15 and
um yeah we went for uh for especially
for the clinical application for
geometry system which is advantages
because sourcing large amounts of
quality are b0 can be very challenging
or difficult and for the clinical
cartita manufacturing we developed the
serum free dmpx pandem to be used with
their teeth with a Tex-Mex medium and as
depicted here various starting materials
so healthy donors patient material as
well as cryoprid preserved so um Frozen
patient material
[Music]
um
was was used and there was no effect on
the cell count
as well as on the expansion and on the
viability also shown here for cell count
and for survivability
and yeah especially or what I wanted to
highlight is that also for the Frozen
patient material we will be observed
really high viabilities and expansion
rates
um following this workflow and
cultivation with serum free medium
the medium as well as the cytokines are
available in research grade and in Max
GMP grade and yeah especially for the
research it's so not only especially but
um for the research our cytokines our
premium create cytokines that you also
get a certificate of analysis and can
make sure that you have a
yeah a unit specific dosing to ensure a
really high reproducibility and then
also an easy translation
yeah now I would like to take a look at
the um last step of the workflow the
phenotypic and functional analysis
um in a clinical setting in a
manufacturing setting this is then the
in-process control IPC and quality
control QC but of course you also do it
in a research setting but yes it's not
named ipcqc
um but it's basically
um the same you check yourself and there
are also different options so you can do
it via flow
cytometry but there are also others you
can do ohmic analysis some some of some
do maybe also um stainings or a
real-time qpcr and there are a lot of
more methods to phenotypically
investigate or assess the functionality
of the car T cells
and again here are also things that you
should consider so in terms of the
reproducibility of your flow cytometry
results
um also take a look at taking a look at
the reagents at is the panel performance
confirmed what is about the instrument
harmonization what is about the analysis
this is done this is user dependent for
sure but how can this be done user
independent what is about the reporting
what is about the standardization of the
protocols and so on
and yeah here um we collected some main
sources of variation in flow cytometry
and based on this we also we originally
we established a flow cytometry
standardization concept and there are
different sources of variation so for
example the donor variability this is
patient-driven pre-treatment driven and
also collection driven and there is not
much you can do but there are other
things for example the reagents
um
to ensure a lot to Lots
consistency of your antibodies also for
for instrumentation
um
there is a pipetting variability a
manufacturing tolerance and operational
tolerances then regarding the analysis
and Reporting this is a mainly user
dependent and prone to human error and
also in terms of protocol there are of
course non-optimized procedure and a lot
of manual handling steps which lead to a
lot of variation in their flow cytometry
analysis results
yeah we're just depicted here is our
flow cytometry standardization concept
and yeah the main source of variation
can be basically mitigated by
um our reaffinity antibodies and those
are derived from a defined DNA sequence
um
and they are produced under standardized
conditions and provide a high law to lot
consistency and what's also very nice is
that there's only one identity isotype
so there's no there's only one isotype
control needed for the experimental
setup and also there's no FC blocking
receptor step or reagent needed and all
the reagents are for ipcqc are also
available in clinical quality
so this makes it easy to transfer your
panels from the research setting into
the clinical setting and continue there
but not only the reagent but also the
instruments are made to create reliable
and reproducible flow data and with
their so-called smart gain technology
you can take an instrument setting to
from one device to another and Achieve
equivalent performance
and the idea is to provide really
reliable data from test to test from
user to user and also from instrument to
instrument across different sites and
this is also super interesting if it
then comes to the clinical manufacturing
then we also have our Express modes and
this is a software add-on for our
um
Mexican analyzer software and this
gating adjustment is based on an
algorithm algorithm and this can be used
to avoid variations caused by different
um yeah by different humans by different
operators during the data analysis and
in terms of protocols we also go for a
high degree of optimization
customization if needed and we have a
great application support so if you
would like to learn more about our flow
cytometry standardization concept and we
have a really nice
analytics stay around table a lot of
resources and some really nice webinars
that elaborate a bit more on these
flawsychology standardization Concepts
so feel free to follow
um so there to scan this QR code here
and learn more
now I come to the last part of this
webinar the summary and resource
yeah I hope that it became clear by
thinking translational right from the
beginning
um is really beneficial to streamline
the transition from the research phase
to the pre-clinical development and that
at least some of the considerations I
mentioned at the beginning and during
this webinar will lead to yeah
discussions about your current workflow
to adoptions and that you yeah can
streamline and improve your workflow and
by this also you'll save some resources
time wise money-wise and also your
nerves
on this slide I summarized our Solutions
um
for the research part as well as for the
clinical manufacturing part and as you
can see for every research product I
mentioned in this workflow the GMP
counterpart exists and this is developed
our Solutions are developed
to enable a really a smooth transition
from the research phase to the
clinical pre-clinical development
I also compiled here some of the
resources that I would like to share
with you so the first is our small scale
TCT protocol that has been developed in
cooperation with our r d or it's an r d
protocol basically that they shared and
it is a step-by-step protocol it
includes all the step all the material
all the tips and tricks to engineer T
cells and already some of the customers
are using it and I always get very
positive feedback so take a look
download it and yeah it's it's also for
free then we have also our application
page where you find different product
Solutions but also webinars to different
cartoon topics you find application
notes text sheets
um yeah and a lot of helpful tips and
tricks and a bit oh it's good but still
digital
um is our car T cell research and
Discovery Pro social which also
summarizes nicely all the tools and
product that we offer to support your
research
if you have any questions or you want to
receive a deeper and more extensive
information or personal Consulting about
our Solutions I invite you to contact
our local sales organizations and The
Amity biotech is represented in over 23
countries worldwide and we also have
representatives in a total of 73
countries worldwide so please feel free
to reach out to get in contact and to
get more information
I also want to invite you to follow us
on social media LinkedIn or researchgate
and stay tuned and don't miss our latest
scientific Publications free research
protocols travel Awards and also our
latest product releases
yeah and with this nice image of our
headquarter campus in Burgos Germany at
night I finished my presentation and I
thank you very much for joining this
webinar today and if you have any
specific question to this webinar so
please feel free to write me an email I
will come back to you as soon as
possible and yeah so thanks again and
have a wonderful and productive rest of
the day goodbye